you're known you came to fame on icarly
okay
and on icarly uh and i have uh
younger kids okay and i've watched
someone i've noticed that you're always
screaming is that my imagination or is
your character always screaming
no that's that's pretty accurate yeah i
don't know i mean that just
was that something that they directed
you to do or does that come out of jerry
traynor's personality
that came from what i used to do show
drake and josh before i carly and
i was a crazy all right
okay there you go yeah they like
screaming yeah it's really worked out
for me so on that show you do something
i was a crazy person that screamed all
the time i was
quiet and then i would scream and then
and then i was spencer and i would
scream even more and
and so now i just call it kind of
falling into this screaming path
i uh it's it's well known in the vocal
world
uh that uh that screaming will destroy
your voice yeah if you scream it's the
surest way to lose your voice
correct have you had vocal problems well
i used to
really worry about it but i i just kind
of have found a way
to not i don't put the screen right on
my vocal cords i kind of
it's more like a gargle i don't know
what you're talking about right
well you're not a professional in the
vocal world
well andy andy does a lot of voice over
do you know what world
yeah but i i well yeah you don't you can
do it with
you open your throat up and then it's
like oh you know it's not well that's
like if you're an opera singer
yeah andy is an opera singer by the way
i am a horrible one yeah terrible yeah
yeah we're always asking him to stop and
he's not professional
but what do you do so what's your you
gargle give me an example
ah it's like up on the uvula so it's
like if i scream it's like
see i gotta warn the sound people
because it's like
don't ask me it's like up here right
it's that cause i get off my lawn
yes you know you're way too young to be
yelling at people to get off i'm not
get out hold on i'll tell you you're not
supposed to be doing that my baseball
now
jeremy and then i keep it
wow okay well good for you so it's also
vocal you're prepared but you're a
horrible man
apparently